-You know what, guys?
Those were mostly
pretty good jokes, I think.
But our monologue writers
write pages and pages of jokes
every day and, um,
they're not all good
and, honestly, sometimes,
sometimes I think they just like
throw in some real stinkers,
just to fill up a page
and meet the assignment.
Baze, I think that's
probably accurate, right?
So, anyways, Baze and I got
to talking, you know,
because it's understandable
that they fill out the pages,
but, we're about to have
audiences back
and, that kind of laziness
really has to stop,
which means it's time
for a "Surprise Inspection."
[ Trumpet plays march ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
And then, maybe tomorrow
we'll do one for graphics?
[ Laughter ]
So, here's how this works.
These are real jokes
that were actually submitted
by our writers,
that are unusable for this show.
Some are dumb,
some are patently offensive,
and some are baffling.
Most importantly, the writers
don't know we're doing this
and, because a lot of them
don't watch the show,
they'll never know
we're doing it.
[ Laughter ]
Here we go.
U.S. wildlife officials
announced today
that 22 animals and one plant
have become extinct,
including the Bachman's warbler.
Thankfully, Bachman's warbles
will live on forever,
♪ Taking care of business ♪
[ Laughter ]
So that --
that joke was dependent
on people knowing that song,
"Taking Care of Business,"
was performed
by Bachman-Turner Overdrive.
[ Laughter ]
The rare audible "Ugh"
from Shoemaker.
[ Laughter ]
That was Goldich?
That was Matt Goldich?
Let's take a look
at a photo of Goldich.
There you go.
[ Laughter ]
That's the man
who wrote that joke.
That's the face he made
when we told him
we were going to do it
in the show tonight.
[ Laughter ]
A house outside --
Alright, here we go.
A house outside of Boston
that recently caught fire
and partially burned down
was listed for sale last month.
For more on this, check out...
[ Laughter ]
So that's a joke where,
either you've seen the film
and you're aghast
at the punch line;
or you haven't seen the film
and then, you would go,
you'd watch the film,
and then you would be aghast
after that.
So that was courtesy of Ian.
Let's take a look at Ian.
[ Laughter ]
Who, I guess, wrote that joke
and then, we took a photo of him
having an orgasm.
[ Laughter ]
The pharmaceutical company
Pfizer announced yesterday
that it has submitted data
to the FDA
about its coronavirus vaccine
in children ages five and older.
"Damn it, right when I got
to go to prison,"
said R. Kelly.
[ Laughter and oohs ]
Again, offensive, but way more
baffling than offensive.
I mean,
I hate to defend the man.
But I feel like five
was a little younger
than the target
and this joke implies
that his fear --
Go back up a card, Wally.
So, "Damn it, right when I go
to prison," because he was --
It implies that like his fear
was getting coronavirus.
[ Laughter ]
It just stinks.
It was written by Mike Scollins.
Let's take a look at him.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Passengers
on a Spirit Airlines plane
in Atlantic City, New Jersey,
were forced to deplane
over the weekend
after a large bird caused
an engine fire,
which is an extremely rude
thing to call
the flight attendant.
A large bird.
[ Laughter ]
So,
I guess that would be like
British slang.
Like this would maybe work,
if it was British Airways
or Michael Caine Airlines.
[ Laughter ]
Karen wrote that.
Let's take a look at her.
There she is.
[ Laughter ]
Shame on you, Karen.
Producers announced yesterday
that James Bond actor
Daniel Craig will next year star
in a Broadway production
of "Macbeth."
Said Craig,
"The name's Beth.
Macbeth."
[ Laughter ]
Bryan wrote that.
Here he is.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study --
Well, I hate to do this
to you, Wally.
-What?
-I'm going to surprise inspect
your cue card.
You wrote "new" twice.
-Oh, yeah.
-Turn it to the camera.
-Which one?
-"According to a new new study."
We caught Wally, too.
-It could've been really new.
-What?
-It could've been like
really new,
so that's why we wrote --
[ Laughs ]
-Do you think that's
how scientists say it?
"We have a new, new study."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, probably not.
-You guys.
-Probably not.
Okay.
-According to a new,
new study...
[ Laughter ]
...mice have feelings
of sadness and depression.
Asked scientists,
"Did they say if it was because
of the cancer we gave them?"
[ Laughter ]
So, again -- Ally wrote that.
Let's take a look at Ally.
So there was a new study,
so a different set of scientists
did the study
and then the first set
of scientists
read the study and was like,
"Uh-oh."
Today --
Oh, Scollins is back, everybody.
[ Laughter ]
Today was National Vodka Day
and it's about to Popov.
[pop off]
[ Laughter ]
See?
I could never --
I mean, there's like
courtesy laughs
from the people who work here
because they know Scollins.
But like, once we have
strangers back,
they're going to be angry.
[ Laughter ]
The Munich Airport in Germany
was put into lockdown last week
after a man allegedly tried
to go through security
with a live mortar shell
that he forgot was
in his book bag.
Said the man, "Oh, my God,
I should've eaten
this before getting here."
[ Quiet laughter ]
Nothing.
And they like you, Karen.
[ Laughter ]
The people here like you.
In honor of Disney World's
50th anniversary,
Southwest Airlines has unveiled
a commemorative
custom-designed plane
that features an outline
of Cinderella's Castle
on the outside, but head's up --
the inside is still
full pumpkin.
-[ Chuckle ]
-The castle.
Now, part of it --
Again, if it was
the carriage,
full pumpkin would maybe work.
The castle wasn't a pumpkin.
It's Ian again.
Let's take a look.
Oh, he's fine.
[ Laughter ]
Audiences are coming back.
This is very serious.
And I feel like the seriousness
of this moment
is going to be undercut
in a second
when we see
the title card again,
but I really want you guys
to start focusing on the work.
This has been
"Surprise Inspection."
[ Trumpet plays march ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪